Ils ont vu tous les Pirates des Caraïbes
Ce sont des Youtubers
Ils adorent les trésors et l'argent
Et aujourd'hui, il vont former un équipage
De luxe
Mais sans Gotaga, il est pas là
Bienvenue Laink, Terracid, Cyril et Mika
Aujourd'hui on va aborder des gens, on va les buter
Et on va voler leurs trésors
Eh puta*n... mais... je... je...
Arrêtez de me laisser bider à chaque intro de vidéo !
Les autres : Mais c'est là qu'il fallait parler, j'te demandais !
Non mais moi, j'en peux plus...
Les amis, il y a deux manières de gagner
Soit on bourrine de boulets le bateau ennemi et va couler et on a gagné
Soit on le grap et on fait un abordage et on les tue tous, et on a gagné
Du coup les amis, je propose d'y aller
Je monte à la barre
J'ai le barreau car ce jeu à l'air bien
Musique*
Les gars on va à la vitesse maximale
Je vais juste faire en sorte qu'on se prenne pas une île
Charger les canons de devant et du coté droit
Cyril : *ARG*
Ah, euh...
Mais pourquoi t'es mort ?
Mais pourquoi t'es mort ??
J'ai glissé sur la vigie
Mais Putaaaaaaaaiiiin
Cyril est mort !
Ok les gars le bateau est en face
Attention, est-ce que vous êtes prêt à tirer avec les deux canons de devant ?
Sautez qui peut !
Est ce qu'on est à distance ?
Ça se tente ! Ça se tente ! Ça se tente !
FEUUUUUUUU !
C'est raté !
Un peu à droite. Un peu à droite. J'suis un peu à droite.
Vas-y ! Vas-y ! Vas-y !
Bourrine-les !
Oui c'est bon, on les a touchés !
Continue comme ça, on leur fonce dedans !
Grappez avec les canons de droite !
Terracid : Je te tire
C'est bien Terra !
Terracid : C'est bon on a grippé !
C'est parti les gars, on va les ba*seeeer !
Oh j'me suis fait OneShot
Je suis mort
Terra tout repose sur toi, tu es le second capitaine
Terracid : Personne pensera à m'chercher ici ?
Il est là tu l'a vues
Noooon !
Mais non !
Bon, on ne va rien dire !
T'étais derrière un mur, normalement il ne pouvait pas te toucher, mais c'est pas grave.
C'est un très bon jeu, achetez-le.
Les amis, c'est une défaite, je ne vais pas vous mentir
Je suis très déçu !
Laink : Même par moi, capitaine ?
OUI !
J'aimerai que tout le monde y mette un peu plus du sien...
et que mes ordres soient exécutés.
Laink : Même moi ? *rires*
Oui !
Ferme ta gueule !
Les amis, n'oubliez pas, des canons devant, des grappins à droite, ok ?
*OK*
*rires*
Cyril : Capitaine, j'suis mort !
Mais puta*n !
Mais Cyril !
Cyril : Mais il y a des flaques d'eau partout moi, comment voulez-vous que je fasse ?
Vous êtes vraiment le pire équipage de ma carrière.
J'ai jamais eu des... des tels glandeurs sur un bateau, mais bon.
*À droite !*
Prenez à droite les gars, embuscade !
Ils ne nous ont pas vu !
On les prend en filature, vous êtes prêts ?
Là, je vais tourner à droite
Préparez les deux canons de devant, on va leur mettre des boulets de canon dans le cul les gars, ok ?
*Ok, après c'est flanc droit ou flanc gauche ?*
*Euh... Flanc au chocolat !
C'est pas drôle...
Euh, le prochain qui fait une blague comme ça, je... le jette à l'eau !
*C'est tiré !*
Oui, c'est bon !
Allez, continue, continue, recharge les canons !
On est derrière eux, ils sont en panique !
Allez, tirez-leur dessus les gars !!
*J'en ai eu un !*
Ok, les gars, je descends, je vais descendre de là.
Y a des mecs dans la cave en face, attention...
Oh puta*n, Mika est mort !
Tout le monde est en train de mourir !
Les amis ! Vous allez charger les canons du côté gauche, je répète, du côté gauche du bateau !
J'ai mis les voiles, attendez avant de tirer ! Attendez mon... mon go !
Parce qu'ils vont aussi vite que nous, ces gros brigands !
Attends, je vais partir un petit peu exprès
De manière à ce que...
*Tourne encore un peu !*
Ouais !
*Encore un peu !*
OUAIS !!
TIREZ !!
OHHHH !!
ALLEZ LES GARS, ON LES BA*IIIISE !!
On les ba*se, ils savent plus quoi faire !
Ok , chargez les canons de devant, on va leur mettre des boulets de canon dans le cul !
*Les canons de devant, ils sont chargés !*
Ils sont chargés ?
Ok, attention, préparez-vous à tirer !
3... 2... 1...
TIIIIREEEEZZZZ !!
VOILAAAA !!
Ok à gauche, est-ce que vous êtes prêts à gauche, à tirer ?
*Bientôt, capitaine !*
Eh bah, euh... débrouillez-vous !
Ok les gars, on aborde, on aborde, on aborde, on aborde, on aborde !
Allez-y, allez-y, allez-y, explosez-les, explosez le bateau !
Cyril : On est en train de couler, capitaine !
Mais non, on n'est pas en train de couler, ça c'est une illusion d'optique, t'en fait pas !
On est pas en train de couler !
Ferme-la, toi !
Voilà, je l'ai eu.
Je pompe !
Cyril : Je crois qu'on est en train de couler hein !
Réparez, réparez le bateau, réparez le bateau moussaillon !
Puta*n, je me sens vraiment fort.
Cyril : On est en train de pomper !
Vas-y, pompe, pompe, pompe !
Je sais pas ce que t'es en train de faire, mais pompe !
Ok, mettez des grappins sur la gauche, sur la gauche des grappins, sur la gauche !
*C'est bon, grappin chargé capitaine !*
Ok, à gauche vous êtes prêts à grapper ?
*Prêt !*
C'EST PARTIIII !!
C'est grappé !
Les amis, là ça va se battre !
Oh, j'suis mort !
Ils m'ont tué pendant que je conduisais !
*Non, pas le capitaine !*
*Pleurs*
Cyril : Eh, j'suis prêt à grapper devant capitaine, ça y est !
C'est trop tard, c'est trop tard, ça n'a plus aucune utilité !
Allez les gars, ba*sez-les, ba*sez-les, ba*sez-les, ba*sez-les !
Ok, j'ai... Ah, tiens, il y en a un deuxième.
*Ils sont où ? Ah, sur le bateau !*
Ah, non, Terra !
*Pleurs*
*J'y vais !*
Vas'y, Mika !
Il va te tirer dessus,Mika.
*Attention, Mika, attention !*
Oh, oui, tireur en esquive, l'esquive du tonneau !
Oui, le dernier, le dernier, Mika Mika Mika
*Mais il lui en faut combien, des coups ?*
*C'est bon !*
*On a gagné !*
*On a gagné ? Ah bon ?*
Les amis, je suis fier de vous !
Je suis fier de nos manoeuvres
Je suis fier de notre skill !
Bravo à tous !
Terracid : Merci, Serg... Capitaine !
Les amis !  Postulez tous en tant que capitaine et on va élire un nouveau capitaine
Cyril : Je promet du thé a foison
Ouais..
euh..
Cyril : Le soir y aura de la gnôle et des femmes
J'vote pour Cyril
" Ouais ! "
*Rire*
Je donne 100 000 euros aux Youtubers !
Ok, on vote tous pour Mika
Ok, je vote Mika
Non..
Et voilà Mika est capitaine ce qui est bien c'est qui l'a jamais joué au jeu
donc on va vraiment se faire enculer
Ho merde
Ok les canons à droite sont prêts je répète
les canons à droite sont prêts !
Oh bateau tout droit !
Ok attends je vais tirer, attention ..
FEU !!
Ça touche
Ça touche, ÇA TOUCHE !
Et j'ai baisé un mec avec le boulet !
HOO je fais tomber mon café !
Coté droit, je suis prêt, je suis prêt
JE SUIS PRÊT
Ok je le vois arriver, je le vois arriver !
Éloigne-toi, éloigne-toi, vas un peu plus vers la gauche
On va faire une retournée acrobatique avec un bateau
Ça arrive, ça arrive préparez-vous
Est-ce que vous êtes prêts ?
Ouais !
Tirez bande de cons !
Mais non j'ai tiré trop tôt putain !
Mais on a un capitaine pourri là putain !
Aaaa on a pris cher !!
ON A PRIS CHER !?
AAAH Y'A L'EAU QUI MONTE ! Y'A L'EAU QUI MONTE !!
POMPEZ !!
Micka : ON A PERDU UNE VOILE !
COMMENT ON POMPE ?
OK je bois je sais plus quoi faire je bois c'es tout ce que je peux faire
Oh oui ! Vas-y je pompe, je pompe, je pompe
Mais boit pas le thé BORDEL ! Dans une situation pareille !
Cyril : J'ai besoin de mon thé, j'suis en situation de stress, écoute faut que je me détende
Allez y baisez les, baisez les, les canons, les canons, les canons, remplissez les canons pendant que je pompe, bande de SAL*PE !
Ok ok ok
Cyril : C'est parti FEU ! BOUGE PLUS BOUGE PLUS !
VAS-Y BOUGE PLUS !
FEU !
" et boum ! "
Oh c'est beau ça !
ET BOUM ! ET PUTAIN CE QU'ON EST EN TRAIN DE LEUR METTRE !?
On continue de charger mon gars
Attention !!!
FEU !!!
Et bim j'lai raté -40 !
Micka : Côté droit, côté droit armer !
Côté droit
Mais attends tu fais des 360 avec le bateau ou quoi ? Ça change tout le temps!
" Attend avance encore un peu "
OK GOOO !!!!
BOUM !!
Oh ce qu'on leurs a mis !
*Rires*
Ce qu'on leurs a mis !
Ils sont en train de couler !
*Rires*
RECHARGEZ VITE !
Chargez des grappins, on va les aborder !
Mettez les grappins côté droit
Cyril : Ça va taper !
Ça a tapé de quel côté ?
Oh putain y a un trou
Oh putain y a deux trous
Vas-y on répare, on répare, on répare, on répare en temps réel, on s'en bat les steaks
Retourne un peu à gauche, un peu à gauche Mika ! Un peu à gauche, un peu à droite, un peu à droite, un peu à droite
Micka : Je tourne
Ralenti ! VAS A DROITE ! AH ! J'AI FAILLI MOURIR !
C'est l'enfer en bas
alors mec c'est vraiment l'enfer on en peut plus quoi
ALLEZ VA A DROITE MICKA TOURNE A DROITTTEEEEE !!!
Micka : MAIS PUTAIN MAIS JE TOURNE MAIS Y TOURNE PAS CE BATEAU DE CON
MAIS TOURNE A DROITTTTTEEEEEE !!!!
Micka : Mais je tourne mais il tourne aussi !!
Ok les gars attention je vais tenter un grappin, attention, attention, attention
Est-ce que je vais changer le cours de l'histoire ?
C'est grappé ?
Non j'ai grappé l'eau. Nickel il est vraiment bien ce jeu
Capitaine s'il te plaît rapproche toi on va être à court de boulet, on va être à court de tout, et je tire dans le vide
Micka : LES GARS JE LEUR FONCE DESSUS JE M'EN BATS LES COUILLESSS !!!
NON, NON, NON, FAIT PAS ÇA, FAIT PAS ÇA, FAIT PAS ÇA !!
Micka : SI C'EST PARTIT !!!
Micka : CÔTÉ DROIT GRAPPEZ LE !!!
J'lai grappé les gars ! On a tout grappé avec Laink !
On a foutu le feu !
Cyril : J'en ai eu un
Ok les amis, on y va, on y va, ils ont deux morts, ils ont deux morts !
Oh non ! Maintenant Lucas !
Oh non Terra! Lucas il faut y aller ! Je sais ! Ah !
Ils ont tiré le grappin ! Faut se les faire, faut se les faire !
Aller, faut sauter, faut y aller Mika. Faut y aller ! On y va, on y va Mika !
On y va !
"Aaah ! J'suis tombé à l'eau !"
J'le vois courir avec sa calvitie !
*rires*
C'est bon j'l'ai eu ! J'l'ai tué !